PC gamers got to experience gone home
way back in 2013 but it's been a bumpy
road for anyone wanting to play it on
consoles fortunately that road is
getting smooth out next month the
fulbright company's masterpiece will
finally hit xbox one and ps4 in January
these versions were previously canceled
when publisher midnight city went
through a financial shake up the matter
seems to have been settled and console
players will finally have their chance
to explore the greenbrier home on
january 12 fulbright handle the port
themselves which meets the game is
identical to its PC counterpart that
said it's running on an updated engine
and includes over 90 minutes of
behind-the-scenes footage gone home
originally received a 9.5 from gamespot
review Rick arilinn Pettit said the
reason the play gone home is not for its
importance it's for the elegance with
which its tail is constructed and
communicated and the captivating way
that it makes you an active participant
and peeling back the layers of one
family's ordinary lives as their home
tells you their stories you can look
forward to experiencing those stories
yourself in a few short weeks for now
keep it locked in GameSpot for all your
gone home needs I'm Tony Wilson you can
follow me on twitter at chain-gun pope
and i'll be rocking some riot girl
cassette tapes in the meantime